today I'm going to give you a quick
rundown of everything you need to know
before you see the ballot of song birds
and snakes the new Hunger Games prequel
movie that's releasing on November 17th
2023 also don't worry this video is
spoiler-free so you can watch it without
ruining any surprises now it's time to
know before you go first of all let's
get some background on The Hunger Games
series The Hunger Games is a Trilogy of
novels by Suzanne Collins published
between 2008 and 2010 that follows the
story of Katniss everine a teenage girl
who lives in a post-apocalyptic Nation
called panm panm is divided into 12
districts that are oppressed by a
wealthy and tyrannical Capital every
year the capital forces each district to
send two children called tributes to
participate in a brutal televised Death
Match called The Hunger Games the last
tribute alive wins food and riches for
their District while the rest are killed
the novels were adapted into four
blockbuster movies starring Jennifer
Lawrence as Katniss Josh Hutcherson as
Peta malar her fellow tribute and love
interest and Liam Hemsworth as Gail
Hawthorne her best friend and rebel Ally
the movies were released between 2012
and 2015 and grossed over $2.9 billion
worldwide the ballot of song birds and
snakes is a prequel novel that was
published in 20120 it takes place 64
years before the events of the original
trilogy during the 10th Hunger Games
only a decade after the uprising that
started the Hunger Games song birds and
snakes reintroduces panm as a struggling
post-war Nation the games are not yet
the spectacle they will become instead
they're a militant punishment a
straightforward fight to the death
between malnourished teenagers it also
tells the story of Cory Elena snow a
young man who will later become the
ruthless president and Main antagonist
of The Hunger Games trilogy snow is a
top student at the Academy a prestigious
School in the capital where he's
selected to be a mentor for one of the
tributes in The Hunger Games he is
assigned to Mentor Lucy greybeard a
charismatic singer from District 12 the
prequel novel explores the origins of
Snow's character and how he became the
villain we know from the original series
it also shows how The Hunger Games
evolved from A Primitive and unpopular
event to a sophisticated and influential
spectacle the novel also introduces new
characters and aspects of M's history
and culture such as the kovi a group of
traveling performers who live in
district 12 another thing to keep in
mind is that the peacekeepers are the
people who Patrol the districts on the
surface they're tasked with maintaining
order but more often than not they're
trying to discourage Rebellion against
the capital they tend to have riot gear
and weapons the latter of which they use
in the original trilogy to whip or shoot
residents who ignore orders or give the
three-finger mocking J Salute song birds
and snakes takes a closer look at how
people become peacekeepers also the name
Tigris should sound familiar in the
Hunger Games books and movies Tigers is
a capital resident who provides Katniss
and the other Rebels refuge in her first
shot in mocking jay part two tigers has
a face tattooed with Tiger stripes and
whiskers on her cheeks she was a stylist
in the games but stopped after snow
decided she wasn't pretty enough in the
prequel we get a glimpse of tigers's and
Snow's childhoods and quickly learn of
their relationship you might also
remember that Finnick in the book and on
screen revealed that President Snow used
roses to cover the scent of blood in his
mouth those sores says Finnick are
caused by snow poisoning his enemies and
drinking from the same cup to deflect
suspicion snow is often seen among the
roses in his garden and wearing a rose
on his lapel song birds and snakes gives
a backstory on Snow's connection to
those Roses in the mocking jay part one
katna sings the old haunting song about
lovers meeting at the Hanging Tree Pluto
kinby changes up the lyrics for
propaganda film for the Rebellion
against the capital in the film Heavens
be changed the line necklace of rope to
necklace of Hope just keep this in mind
along with the fact that the song was
written long before Katniss was even
born in the mocking jay book the song
has even more significance as something
Katniss remembers her dad singing a tune
that Peeta also recalls this song
becomes very important in song birds and
snakes in case you forgot in penm a
mocking jay is a bird that mimics
Melodies and goes on to be the symbol of
the Rebellion Katniss becomes the
embodiment in the mocking jay and in
Catching Fire memorably shows off a
wedding dress that turns into a black-
winged mocking jay costume eventually
President Snow Outlaws all images of
Mocking Jays you can expect to learn
more about the birds in the movie the
prequel movie is directed by Francis
Lawrence who also directed the last
three movies of the original series this
film is expected to be faithful to the
novel but may also include some changes
and additions to enhance the Cinematic
experience so there you have it
everything you need to know before you
see the ballot of song birds and snakes
if you're a fan of The Hunger Game
series or if you're curious about how it
all began you definitely don't want to
miss this movie don't forget to like And
subscribe or check out the video on your
screen for more of my
content